hello readers today we're going to talk
about mind reading
also known as understanding characters
thoughts and feelings
i'm kind of serious here one of the
things that i think is magical about
reading books and stories is that they
let you see what characters are thinking
and feeling sometimes a story takes you
inside the mind of a character in a
story
here's what it sounds like when a
character tells you the story herself
it was a rainy miserable night in the
town of roseville
my coffee cooled rapidly in the evening
air
i watched johnny flamingo the duke of
crime walk confidently across the
parking lot
i hated him i'm gonna get you johnny i'm
muttered i'm gonna get you for doing all
those crimes
so how does this character feel about
johnny flamingo she hates him how do we
know she told us so
sometimes it's not a character who tells
you what they're thinking or feeling but
instead it's a narrator who knows how
those characters feel and that can sound
like this standing on a hill outside her
little village lana looked to the sky
and the dragons that flew through the
clouds in lazy circles
i will learn to ride a dragon she
thought
i promise
what does lana want to learn to do ride
dragons did she tell us no not exactly
but the narrator did by listening to her
thoughts
do you see what i'm saying it's magical
this ability to read a character's mind
in a story if i had the power to fully
hear my friends thoughts i don't think
we'd ever have any kind of
misunderstandings ever again
how a character thinks or feels about
something is important evidence that
helps explain why they act the way they
do
now it's possible to have a feeling or a
thought but still do something opposite
like a character could be afraid of
heights but still climb a tree to rescue
a cat
or it's possible for a character to feel
multiple conflicting emotions or
thoughts at the same time just like it's
possible for you or me to feel
embarrassed and proud at the same time
or happy and regretful
let's take a look at this example
it's not so bad
said zeke examining it closely when he
saw my frown
it's a bowling pin right
i tried to remain calm but i was totally
frustrated i spent all that time and
zeke thought my statue was a bowling pin
it gritted my teeth as i forced a smile
um no
not exactly
but it's not quite done yet
i grabbed the sculpture and headed to my
room i was determined to make lady
liberty recognizable i decided to watch
a video on how to make realistic faces
in clay
it was helpful although it took me a
while i finally made some improvements
to my work of art
see how the narrator says they're
frustrated but they don't show it to
zeke they force themselves to smile and
not display their frustration
they're trying to be calm
but inside
they're totally frustrated so i guess
the lesson here is that the magic of
mind reading is only part of the story
you have to go by how characters in a
story act too
but we'll talk about that in another
video
you can learn anything
dave it out